let's see what matt's got for us go
ahead buddy
uh can you hear me yeah
awesome uh thanks for the content i
highly recommend the 10
uh it's been a great um great
opportunity while i've been in it uh but
my thought my question was just about
green flags i mean i'm 21 not looking to
get an ltr or any of that but um
if you were to find somebody that has
all the green flags none of the red ones
and you're with them for a long enough
period of time would it even make sense
to get married or would you still say
not at all
look i'm
i'm an older guy how old are you
21. yeah so at 21 i'm not even going to
convince you of this but no i wouldn't
do it knowing knowing what i know now
what like what i've just talked about
like why would you
expose yourself to that level of risk
that's it's it's like taking a six
shooter
loading it up
probably with about four maybe five
bullets and then starting to pull the
trigger and passing it around sort of
thing you're gonna get hit
it's not off you don't get like you know
the dave dodge story i don't know that
you're gonna see that today i don't know
that you're gonna see much of that
anymore yeah i agree i mean i haven't
found girls that are even
because of the internet and all the
systems like are you a natural alpha
like how long you've been red pilled
um i mean
uh
i've been uh i guess consuming the
content for more than a year now and i
started seeing your community recently
okay so it's still new for you so like
that's the point that i'm making so i
mean
you're still gonna have a hard time
dealing with a check in a marriage even
if you've like watched a bunch of my
videos read my book gotten the you know
conversations with guys like moth and
jaron right you're still going to have
relapses you're still going to do stupid
[ __ ] like you're still going to have a
field report where it's like
[ __ ] this is going on and how do i solve
this and
you know unless you've got solid game
like
you don't even want to live with a woman
period right just date
because as soon as you invite a chick in
your life that really changes the
dynamics it's not all fun and games
anymore
now there's why did you leave that over
there where are you going what time are
you going to be back who is that that
was calling you on the phone
none of your business
right so i mean like you have to start
with that very early on and and quash it
let's you know so the point of some of
these blog entries where guys were
talking about power right like you look
like she has to follow your lead
gotcha right i mean you know dave dodge
was so powerful in his relationship at
that time when they wanted to move him
around in the army he said we're gonna
break up
right
that's you know that's a power move so
yeah i mean
just hey look man you got a nice girl in
your life
no no
you're just hypothesizing i'm gonna spin
plates you know maybe she shows up yeah
it's more of just a question i wanted to
ask opposed to you rather than anything
i'm gonna use i'm 21 i'm not looking to
get it so
so what's wrong with just dating her
then you know you're 21 you don't want
to get married you don't want to have
kids any time soon so what's wrong with
just dating her then like why would you
even ask a question like that
oh um
yeah yeah you're right
yeah
look dude i get it you've watched all
the disney shows i did too you probably
saw some sitcoms you know where it looks
like the ideal thing and it's
interesting sort of life to live i get
it i get it you know it's in all the
movies and you know hollywood and all
that sort of stuff but just like
marinade on this is like one of the
biggest decisions you'll ever make in
your entire [ __ ] life is the chick
that you invite into your house
okay i mean guys will spend more time
researching a power tool
and the battery life and how many volts
and whether or not it was made in a
factory in china or in taiwan guys will
spend all that time researching all that
[ __ ] for a [ __ ] power tool but they
won't take the time to vet a check or to
understand you know what women are
actually attracted to and how to
maintain a long-term relationship how to
set boundaries
how to solve next you know like stuff
like that
you get it though right
yeah yeah it makes perfect sense thanks
yeah no but it's a good question thanks
brother hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you